Annie's a legend isn't he the guy so
I've been quite busy this week and run
out of time to do a bigger more in-depth
video so I thought I'd do is share with
you a quick tip that I found and if you
like this format then I might do more of
these kinds of videos in future because
I'll often come across interesting news
or quick tips etc and if I make shorter
videos that means I can do more of them
and post more frequently so this one
comes from France Niger and from
beardies channel beardy being guy who
finds really interesting footage mostly
on Bruce Lee but also on Arnie and
jean-claude Van Damme and remasters it
and shares it with people so one here he
found a relatively recent interview with
ours France [ __ ] which is talking about
a technique he uses in order to keep his
abs looking flatter and more toned and
what's interesting is that it kind of
obviously follows on from another
interview I've seen him do previously
where he talks about something very
similar so if we're combining these
things then we can insinuate that Arnie
uses this interesting practice to
improve his posture and his abs so the
idea is simple you stand against a wall
with your back and your head straight
and your chest puffed out standing tall
and proud and at the same time you suck
in your abs using a vacuum technique
using your transverse abdominus oh
you're holding in your abs bringing your
belly button in towards your spine as
much as you can and holding it there and
Ani says he'll hold this for 15 seconds
and he'll then break and then he does it
twice more so three reps of 15 seconds
and he says we do this every single day
the idea is that you're going to ingrain
these patterns into your brain and
remind your brain that one of its
functions as he puts it is to hold your
stomach in and to keep your posture
straight so a lot of people slump as
they get older a lot of guys allow their
guts to hang out and they have beer
bellies and partly this is due to poor
health generally you know gaining weight
etc are not moving enough sitting with
bad posture at the computer where you're
often hunched over typing but it's also
due to the simple fact that we kind of
forget how to use those muscles and we
relax them too often we still have the
strength and the ability to stand up
straight we just forget so if you
practice every day stay
upstraight holding your abs in like so
then the idea is that eventually it
becomes a habit it becomes second nature
and you'll always stand taller you'll
always have a flatter stomach so I heard
about the posture aspect of this in the
previous video like I said and then more
recently I discovered that he also
recommends doing this for your abs using
the vacuum I haven't had a chance to
practice doing both yet and to see what
the results would be but it'll it makes
a lot of intuitive sense to me I mean it
makes sense that by practicing holding
your gut in by practicing standing up
tall and doing it on a regular basis you
become better at doing both those things
and both those things should result in
lots of other positive changes in your
life I certainly could do with having a
slightly flatter stomach and I could
certainly do I think with improving my
posture so I'll let you know how it
turns out when I've given it a go 3
times 15 seconds with a short break in
between we talked about a minute of
exercise a minute of your time every day
if it has those benefits then it's
certainly worthwhile that's why I
thought it would be interesting to share
with you on this channel like I say I've
got many more of these quick tips to
share if you're interested and I might
also cover a little bits of news I've
heard recently about someone using a
myostatin injection in his own arm to
increase his strength through genetic
mutation that's pretty cool not
necessarily a good idea but certainly
something called the discus that's kind
of in line with this topic with this
channel so if you like that kind of
thing let me know down below and I'll do
more quick tips and news bites
otherwise stay tuned and coming up soon
we'll be more in-depth longer videos and
all the usual stuff on brain training
fitness martial arts productivity
bodybuilding running etc parkour you
name it so if that all sounds good then
thanks a ton for watching and I'll see
you next time bye for now